lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
discutir lo que significa ser un metal
o la naturaleza metálica primero solo
pensemos en los metales que encontramos
en la vida diaria o basándonos en
nuestra experiencia cosas que asociamos
con ser un metal los elementos que
realmente se nos ocurren como metales a
los que siempre nos referimos como un
metal de los que siempre decimos y eso
es metal o eso es metálico son elementos
como el hierro
hierro
mikel
o
y cobre
o plata
y oro
y aluminio
por lo menos para mí estos son los que
se me ocurren inmediatamente
he visto a estos elementos antes y todos
parecen ser metales para mí pero
pensemos en que tienen estos elementos
de otros elementos en la tabla periódica
que les da esta naturaleza metálica que
asociamos con tener una naturaleza
metálica una es que estos elementos
pueden ser brillosos estos elementos
tienden a ser
yang
un tipo de brillo cuando la luz se
refleja en ellos no es como un color
lodo se ven metálicos literalmente esa
es algunas veces la palabra que se usa
para eso tienen un brillo metálico otra
cosa con la que los asociamos es que
tienden a ser tienden a ser bastante del
sol
si yo tomo un metal un bloque de metal y
si lo dejo caer en agua lo imagino
hundiéndose y no flotando en la
superficie del agua también los
imaginamos teniendo un punto de fusión
muy alto tienden a hacer
sí
da
y nada
bien
sólidos a temperatura ambiente y como
veremos esto aplica para todos los
metales excepto uno el cual es mercurio
es brillante pero a temperatura ambiente
como sabrás está en su estado líquido
y otras características que asocio con
un metal son que puedo hacer artículos a
partir de ellos puedo doblarlos y darles
forma en diferentes maneras si pienso en
lámina de aluminio puedo doblarla no
sólo se romperá puedo doblarla en
distintas formas incluso elementos como
el hierro podría tomar mucha presión
hacerlo pero son flexibles son maleables
definitivamente elementos como el oro la
plata y el cobre puedes incluso moldear
los en diferentes tipos de joyería si lo
sometes a presión es más probable que se
doble a que se rompan y solo cortarlos
así que pongamos maleabilidad son
lee
bliss
y maleables y otra cosa que asocio con
los metales es que son buenos
conductores de electricidad conducen
col
du
leex
see that
un lugar en donde siempre verás metal en
tu vida y si abres tus aparatos
electrónicos verás cables estos pueden
estar hechos de cobre podrían tener
componentes hechos de otros metales como
oro plata o algún otro estas son unas de
las propiedades que asociamos con
metales por lo que pensemos en qué
sucede a nivel atómico para dar a estos
elementos estas propiedades la manera en
la que yo pienso en ello es vayamos con
el cobre por un segundo imaginemos solo
un bloque de cobre a nivel atómico
digamos que hay un núcleo de cobre justo
ahí y tiene su mar de electrones tiene
su mar de electrones no tiene un mar de
electrones son electrones en sus
diversos orbitales y hablaremos del mar
de electrones en un segundo pero esto es
como su nube de electrones debería decir
estas son nubes de electrones los
electrones solo están saltando alrededor
en esta nube es realmente una densidad
habilidad hay cierta probabilidad de que
pudiera estar en cualquier punto de esta
nube y entonces solo imaginemos un gran
pedazo de sólido de cobre tendrás
bastantes de estos tendrías varios de
estos todos juntos todos formando el
sólido en lo que le permite a los
metales ser maleables hacer cosas como
conducir electrones o conducir
electricidad la cual es el movimiento de
electrones es esencialmente que
realmente están dispuestos a compartir
electrones entre ellos al compartir
electrones puedes imaginar que este es
un átomo de cobre y este es otro digamos
que están compartiendo algunos
electrones eso es lo que permite que la
electricidad o flujo de electrones
suceda si estos electrones están
enlazados ligeramente y si ponemos una
diferencia de potencial un voltaje
digamos que pones una diferencia de
potencial de tal manera que este lado
sea
negativo que este lado sea más positivo
entonces los electrones querrán alejarse
de la carga negativa y moverse hacia la
carga positiva y si están relativamente
enlazadas libremente se moverán de una
nube a otra dando lugar a lo que es
llamado mar de electrones déjame
escribir eso tienes un mar
y lee
pero mes
de electrones lo que hace lo que hará a
esto conductor y es por eso que están
estables hechos de cobre y el mar de
electrones es también lo que lo hace
maleable si alguien pusiera ya sabes en
este lado mucha presión en esta
dirección y en ese lado pone mucha
presión en esta dirección
objetos rígidos sólo se agrietarán y
romperán se rompería justo ahí pero ya
que tienes un mar de electrones le
permite ser maleable esta parte podría
solo doblarse hacia abajo un poco esta
parte podría doblarse hacia arriba pero
el enlace metálico no se romperá y dado
que esta naturaleza metálica en serio
viene del deseo de estos átomos de
compartir electrones entre ellos de
crear el mar de electrones te invito a
pausar el vídeo y pensar en cuál es
cuáles átomos en la tabla periódica
cuáles elementos son más probables en
hacer eso
en compartir electrones con otros y unos
con otros y este es el mismo principio
que pensamos en la energía de ionización
y en electro negatividad así que pausa
el vídeo asumiré que ya lo intentaste
cuáles elementos son más probables de
compartir electrones ya hemos visto en
la parte izquierda de la tabla periódica
de elementos el grupo 1 por ejemplo sólo
tiene un electrón de valencia sería muy
difícil para ellos obtener electrones
suficientes para completar ese último
orbital y si se den ese electrón de
valencia pueden ir a un estado más
estable por lo que realmente quieren
ceder electrones y estos de aquí están
tan cerca si estamos hablando de si
hablamos de los halógenos están un
electrón lejos de completar su último
orbital concuerdan que quieren abrazar a
estos electrones tienden a ser electro
negativos
los gases nobles ya terminaron ellos
definitivamente no quieren compartir
electrones con nadie están en un estado
muy estable la otra cosa de la que
hablamos es mientras bajamos en un grupo
nuestros átomos se hacen cada vez más
grandes el electrón 55 a bo más alejado
en el cesio tiene un enlace mucho más
débil porque está más lejos que digamos
el tercer electrón en el litio así como
vimos que los elementos abajo en la
izquierda tienen energías de ionización
muy bajas no se necesita mucha energía
para remover un electrón de ellos estos
son los que son más probables de
compartir electrones y estos de hecho
tienen la naturaleza metálica más alta
nada
gran mesa
está
si acá
y los de arriba en la derecha estos eran
lo opuesto es muy poco probable que
compartan electrones son muy electro
negativos tienen una energía de
ionización muy alta tienen una na
esa
metallica
ja
y puedo imaginar que algunas cosas están
surgiendo de tu mente en este punto
empezamos pensando en los elementos de
nuestra vida diaria que asociamos con
metales lo que estoy diciendo es que
estos de aquí incluso tienen una
naturaleza metálica mayor pero qué pasa
en algo como calcio
sabemos diariamente cuando imagino
cuando la mayoría de la gente imagina el
calcio piensa en una sustancia parecida
al gis blanco muy rígida no muy maleable
no muy brillante no muy buena
conduciendo a electricidad basado en lo
que te acabo de decir esto debería tener
una naturaleza metálica más alta que
algo como el aluminio lo que tienes que
recordar es que lo que ves no es
exactamente calcio puro esa sustancia
parecida al gis es carbonato de calcio
el calcio puro esta es de hecho una foto
del calcio puro y es brilloso si tiene
estas propiedades metálicas por lo que
la tendencia general aquí es que todos
estos todos estos tienen naturaleza
metálica muy elevada y estos tienen una
naturaleza metálica muy baja lo que
también podría probablemente hacerte
pensar que la mayor parte de la tabla
periódica es un metal de alguna manera
si el aluminio es un metal
y estas cosas tienen una mayor
naturaleza metálica entonces todos estos
elementos todos estos elementos son
metales y ese es el caso el bloque es el
bloque d el bloque f todos estos son
metales y luego gran parte del bloque p
una gran parte del bloque p son
considerados metales y a éstos algunas
veces se les conoce como metaloides esta
sección de la tabla periódica no es
considerada a un metal eso tiene sentido
porque como gases nobles son gases no
son muy reactivos no se enlazan no
forman un tipo de estructura no cumplen
incluso con este tipo de características
y estos de aquí sabes que incluso el
carbono llega a formar una celosía no
conduce bien electricidad tiende a no
ser muy maleable si piensas en algo como
un diamante o si piensas en no no un
diamante podría ser el mejor ejemplo de
eso espero esto te dé una idea de la
naturaleza metálica y la tendencia en la
tabla periódica alta naturaleza metálica
y si vas hacia arriba a la derecha la
naturaleza metálica cada vez baja más